sie sehen nun die neujahrsansprache des
bundeskanzlers
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger heute
geht ein jahr zu ende dass einige
veränderungen mit sich gebracht hat eine
kleine veränderung heute abend richtig
als ihr bundeskanzler die
neujahrsansprache an sie
der reibungslose mitunter fast
freundschaftliche übergang von der alten
bundesregierung zur neuen hat überall in
der welt viel anklang gefunden
es ist ein gutes zeichen für die stärke
unserer gesellschaft
das jahr 2021 hat uns alle sehr
gefordert die korona pandemie mit ihren
belastungen und tiefgreifenden
einschränkungen steckt uns allen in den
knochen
und auch das verheerende hochwasser
nordrhein westfalen bayern und
rheinland-pfalz niemand so schnell
vergessen
so stimmen beides gewesen ist unsere
reaktion darauf enthält auch eine durch
und durch erfreuliche botschaft
als gesellschaft haben wir in
deutschland diese herausforderung
entschlossen angenommen
nach der flut haben wir alle zusammen
angepackt gemeinsam haben wir geholfen
aufgeräumt und mit dem wiederaufbau
begonnen
damit werden wir übrigens noch lange zu
tun haben
und im kampf gegen die pandemie haben
sich inzwischen mehr als 60 millionen in
unserem land impfen lassen es werden
täglich mehr
manche beklagen in diesen tagen unsere
gesellschaft sei gespalten ich möchte
hier mit aller deutlichkeit sagen das
gegenteil ist richtig unser land steht
zusammen
was ich überall wahrnehme das ist eine
riesige solidarität das ist
überwältigende hilfsbereitschaft das ist
ein neues zusammenrücken und unterhaken
ausdrücklich möchte ich heute allen
danken die sich tagtäglich für unser
wohl einsetzen für unsere gesundheit und
für unsere sicherheit im inland wie im
ausland in krankenhäusern pflegestation
arztpraxen oder impfzentren in den
polizeirevieren und bei der bundeswehr
ich danke ihnen für das was sie für
unser land für uns alle leisten
natürlich erleben wir im täglichen
miteinander auch unterschiedliche
meinungen und einschätzungen gerade zum
thema krone das ist oft anstrengend aber
eine starke gemeinschaft hält
widersprüche aus wenn wir einander
zuhören und wenn wir respekt voreinander
haben
uns allen ist klar die pandemie ist
nicht vorbei leider nach den vergangenen
21 monaten haben wir uns so sehr danach
gesehnt
abermals muss die große silvesterparty
heute abend ausfallen auch auf großes
feuerwerk müssen wir verzichten
wir tun das um das virus nicht weiter zu
verbreiten und unsere krankenhäuser
nicht zusätzlich zu belasten
wir unterstützen damit die arbeit der
pflegerinnen und pfleger der ärztinnen
und ärzte die auch heute nacht dienst
tun
die wir mit bürgern und mitbürger ich
danke ihnen auch ganz persönlich dafür
dass sie sich bemühen sich an die
geltenden regeln zu halten
klar ist auch die nächsten tage und
wochen werden noch ganz im zeichen von
corona stehen das virus hat sich
verändert eine neue variante verbreitet
sich gerade rasant sie haben ihren namen
gehört omikron
viele fragen sich was das für uns nun
wieder heißt ist nun weitergeht ich
verspreche ihnen dass wir schnell und
entschlossen reagieren werden und ich
bin sehr froh dass wir uns auf den rat
von unabhängigen expertinnen und
experten verlassen können
heute und in den nächsten wochen gelten
deutliche beschränkungen auch für
private kontakte
denn das virus überträgt sich in der
neuen omikron variante nun noch leichter
bitte nehmen sie diese beschränkung sehr
ernst zu ihrem schutz zum schutz ihrer
familien zum schutz von uns allen
wir wissen dass diejenigen bisher noch
nicht geimpft sind besonders gefährdet
sind sich anzustecken und lange und
schwerwiegend an der krankheit zu leiden
ich appelliere daher noch mal an sie
lassen sie sich impfen
ich weiß
dass manch einer und manche eine
skeptisch ist sich sorgt die impfung
könnte negative folgen haben
inzwischen sind allerdings fast vier
milliarden menschen auf der ganzen welt
geimpft ohne größere nebenwirkung und
unzählige geimpfte sind eltern von
gesunden babys geworden der nutzen der
impfung ist wirklich groß
gerade die neue virusvariante sollte nun
den ausschlag geben sich impfen zu
lassen dass der weg aus dieser pandemie
meine bitte machen sie gleich in den
nächsten tagen einen termin bei einem
impfzentrum beim arzt oder einer ärztin
nutzen sie die möglichkeiten sich
spontan und ohne anmeldung impfen zu
lassen bitte verschieben sie es nicht
auf demnächst
und alle die bereits geimpft sind bitte
ich eindringlich sich rasch postern zu
lassen sich die dritte impfung zu wollen
dann sind sie im falle einer ansteckung
mit dem virus besser vor einem schweren
verlauf geschützt
jetzt kommt es auf tempo an wir müssen
schneller seien als das virus seit mitte
november haben wir mehr als 30 millionen
impfungen in deutschland hingekriegt so
viele wie würde in keinem anderen land
in der europäischen union
das ist gut wir wollen aber noch besser
werden bis ende januar wollen wir noch
einmal 30 millionen impfungen schaffen
damit wir gewappnet sind gegen omikron
tun wir miteinander alles aber auch
wirklich alles dafür dass wir corona im
neuen jahr endlich besiegen können
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
corona in den griff zu bekommen das ist
die eine große aufgabe im neuen jahr die
andere große aufgabe ist es den
grundstein dafür zu legen dass unser
land weiter gut voran kommt die 20er
jahre werden zu einem jahrzehnt des
aufbruchs
dafür haben wir uns ehrgeizige ziele
gesetzt nicht einmal 25 jahren soll
deutschland klimaneutral sein dafür
werden wir den größten umbau unserer
wirtschaft seit mehr als 100 jahren
voranbringen wir werden uns in diesem
zeitraum unabhängig machen von kohle öl
und gas und gleichzeitig mindestens
doppelt so viel strom wie heute aus
wind- sonnen- und anderen erneuerbaren
energien erzeugen eine gigantische
aufgabe
damit wir sie bewältigen stoßen wir
massive investitionen in neue stromnetze
entlade sollen für elektroautos in
windanlagen entschieden und vieles mehr
das schafft neuen wohlstand und gute
arbeitsplätze als modernes industrieland
werden wir unsere klimaziele erreichen
und unsere technologien gehören weiter
zur weltspitze
ich bin zuversichtlich denn wir haben
alles was es dafür braucht gut
ausgebildete
facharbeiterinnen und facharbeiter kluge
ingenieurinnen und ingenieure aktive
handwerksbetriebe und unternehmen
wir werden die großen veränderungen
unserer zeit gemeinsam und miteinander
meistern können wenn wir als
gemeinschaft zusammenhalten
respekt anerkennung und gute
lebenschancen für alle sind die
voraussetzungen dafür
eine ordentliche bezahlung ist auch eine
frage des respekts deshalb erhöhen wir
den gesetzlichen mindestlohn im
kommenden jahr in einem großen schritt
auf 12 euro und auch das ist mir wichtig
jede und jeder muss von den früchten der
eigenen arbeit auch im alter ordentlich
leben kann
die wir mit bürgern und mitbürger
fortschritt für eine bessere welt dieses
ziel kann kein land allein erreichen das
gelingt nur wenn die internationale
gemeinschaft zusammen daran arbeitet
deutschland übernimmt ab morgen für ein
jahr die präsidentschaft der gruppe von
sieben wirtschaftlich starken
demokratischen staaten der g 7
wir werden unsere präsidentschaft nutzen
damit dieser staaten heißt zum vorreiter
wird zum vorreiter für klimaneutrales
wirtschaften und eine gerechte welt
internationale zusammenarbeit ist
wichtig in einer welt mit bei 10
milliarden einwohnern einwohnern wird
unsere stimme nur dann zu hören sein
wenn wir im chor mit vielen anderen
auftreten
deshalb arbeiten wir auch weiter am
gelingen der europäischen union unser
ziel ist ein souveränes ein starkes
europa ein europa das nach seinen
gemeinsamen werten von frieden
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie lebt
für die sicherheit in europa ist darüber
hinaus die transatlantische
zusammenarbeit unverzichtbar mit blick
auf die ukraine stellen sich uns hier
heute neue herausforderungen die
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen ist ein
hohes gut und nicht verhandelbar
die wir mit bürgern und mitbürger wir
stehen am beginn eines neuen jahrzehnts
wir brechen auf in eine neue zeit eine
zeit gut wird wenn wir sie aktiv
gestalten denn es macht einen
unterschied dass wir unser schicksal
entschlossen selbst in die hand nehmen
für das neue jahr wünsche ich ihnen
alles gute vor allem gesundheit
ein großer wunsch für 2022
bleiben wir zusammen
zum neuen jahr sprach der bundeskanzler